all right victor
victor uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
i was
uh born in peckham england
i grew up
until i was
six or seven
in england uh
romania
bulgaria
a bunch of places
came to america
when i was about
seven um
still continued
uh
thinking so you like this missionary kid
and all that
so you guys moved around a lot
yeah
continue that till i was 11 but i mean
primarily
birth to
seven was the most
prominent movement
was your family like
um
my father is
a very
intelligent man
who
[Music]
is desperate to save the world
because he can't save himself
and he can't save his family
so he's going to kill himself being a
missionary
to try and save the world
to fix it or something
barb
is
the same but
more of a sociopathic
uh
everything's about her
what is it uh that dual personality uh
something like dual personality but it's
not
forget what it's called right now
borderline personality borderline
personality disorder
that about sums up barbara
your mom yeah
how did your parents personalities
impact you as a kid
how does it impact me um
well
until i was
nine
i was afraid of everything in the world
[Music]
gotten lots of fights where people
jumped me but never intended to get in a
fight i just was attacked all the time
because you know the weak pathetic
scared ones generally do
uh
wanted to be like them what else
i was a kid
you felt loved as a kid no
i'm not even
after years of
searching
databases and
online forums and
movies and everything else
i still don't
exactly
understand the definition of uh what
loved
is
i think the closest would be uh
what i feel for uh
my wife
you're married
yeah i am now married
a
lovely lady
who's
going to be dead any month
where is that
uh congenital heart failure
kidney failure liver failure
uh her thyroid doesn't produce
any
chemicals whatsoever
the doctors
told her she had
anxiety disorder et cetera et cetera et
cetera et cetera et cetera a thousand
different things
didn't know what was going on with her
and
then come to find out when
you put a gun to one of their head
and they actually have to look you in
the eye and look your wife in the eye
and look at the paperwork and go over
everything
they're actually pretty good at finding
out what's going on
and so
[Music]
her thyroid hasn't been producing
whatever chemicals thyroids produce i
can't even think of what that is
um
[Music]
for a couple years
whatsoever
uh
she's been
staying alive by
i don't know
willpower and uh
some knowledge i picked up from
my native american
family
taught me with
native herbs and treating
sicknesses and whatnot
you're living on the streets now
yep
and where's your wife
she is
in a
tiny home
in a tiny village
not too far from here
oh for the homeless up in north
hollywood
not in north hartley but yeah yeah one
of their tiny home communities
yeah
the drugs are
a part of your life now how long has
that been going on
oh
she um
[Music]
gotten some type of accident when i was
seven so they started me on
liquid opiate
uh liquid
codeine opiates uh that tasted like
bubble gum
so from pretty much seven on
i mean i shot heroin and knew
[Music]
nah the first time i shot here i didn't
even
have any concepts what it was but i shot
it up uh
i was 11.
um
[Music]
and yeah drugs have been always been
part of my life
painkillers sleeping pills
alcohol
[Music]
anything
sex drugs rock and roll
bdsm
everything
your wife is in a homeless community for
this for drug
related reasons or
no she's in a homeless community because
uh
her family
lost
a son
and
lost a grandmother
and
realistically
she took care of the grandmother
while the mother
couldn't handle it
and so now a little her mother
despises her
can't stand to be around her so
she now has
my wife's daughter
and
[Music]
made sure that she got rid of her
own daughter
on as
far away as possible as
she could
chicago to here
and your drug now is what
sorry your drug currently is
drug is in singular
uh
my drug
which drugs ratio are they uh
what kind of what cocktail are you using
xanax valium
klonopin
heroin
ecstasy
meth
occasionally fentanyl
um
vladim
uh
i
forget the name of that one it's really
good it's got wormwood in it
makes you hallucinate
to drink it's green
put
little
cubes of
sugar on it and set it on fire
absinthe
uh trying at least have one cup of
absinthe for the day
that's getting hard because
i have to make it myself and
it's hard to get a hold of everything
anymore
where are you staying now
uh
staying
well last night i stayed
outside here
um in a tent or just on the street
no i just or you're taking crystal meth
so you don't sleep sat down and uh
went through all my stuff with uh
someone that i met
last night
that we were smoking
pcp and
i think dmt and
some other things and got convinced that
everyone was demons so he said that we
should come down here because
here would be
no demons
um
i guess for him it's probably
like that
older black man
this probably has no demons in this area
me younger white guy
um
i am the demon in this area
what's the hardest part of your
of your life right now
your what your wife's situation yeah the
fact that i have to watch my wife die
and i can't do anything about it
i've already figured that out because
i'm very very very adept at
getting people to do what they need to
do when i feel like
the time has come for me to stop being
nice
and it came
and it went
and it doesn't matter if you're nice or
not
if the doctors are a bunch of [ __ ]
imbeciles
that don't know
they don't know
so
your wife can take
all the
synthetic
hormone
[Music]
[ __ ]
that they give her and
quit drugs and become part of a
community
and
work out
and eat three meals a day
and
[Music]
everything
else and when you go back into the
doctor
after like eight months
when they're done twitching because they
don't
know how to handle being [ __ ]
put to task
like they all should be anyway
why not i was put to task my whole life
why other people get to not be
anyway
i digress
no new news is
not always good news it's just no new
news
uh
or just
same old [ __ ] news she's dying
you need to prepare yourself
have you ever lost somebody
i lost my mom a couple years ago
were you able to prepare yourself
um
yes and no kind of
on some levels yes in other levels no
that's incredible i'm happy for you
yeah really i really wife is young
i assume i'm sorry your wife is young i
assume
uh yeah she's younger than me
uh she is 38
38.
um and this is
going to be my
second time
widowed
so
i guess
in a way i've
adjusted
i've acknowledged what i need to deal
with
i've uh set up for the necessary
legal
[Music]
[ __ ] with uh you know
the government trying to keep her body
if i don't have
enough money to pay for the
pauper's grave
or
her parents deciding that they're just
going to take the body and
move it along and
[Music]
screw you
i've
dealt with all that
so i guess in some ways
i'm prepared
but
not in any meaningful
life enriching
or
even just
a little
less
depleting
way
and drugs help you cope with it all
yeah
drugs are
the only thing either of us has
we make jokes about it all the time
your wife uses as well
she started back up
i got her to quit she was on fentanyl
killing herself off of that
i brought her back nine times
mouth to mouth blah blah
and then
one day said
why am i bringing you back
you obviously want to die
the doctors already said you're gonna
die
what's the point
so she quit
for like seven months
and now
i do what i can to put together money
to
get together
the
heroine and meth and xanax and valium
etc
etc etc and infinium
nauseam truly
uh
to
supply
her habit
what emotions do you deal with mostly
rage
raging [ __ ] hate
and
dying desire
to inflict pain upon this world
so all the pretty people
could have
30 minutes of my life
you know
[Music]
[Applause]
i could put that right through
into your brain
and it would be the kindest thing i ever
did to you
do you have kids
no i watched my wife and daughter die
in a fire your first one
car fire
car bombing really
let's be real
people were after me because i was
starting to make money because i had a
daughter and i didn't know how to deal
with it
and i needed money
to take care of my kid so i started
doing
a version of what my parents did
they were good christian smugglers
i was just a smuggler
then
people got upset at me for doing too
well
because that's how this world
works don't ever think that like you're
supposed to do well
no
know this for a fact because i know this
for a fact
and i've lived life
i've lived more lives than most people
will ever have to [ __ ] face
your job is not to do things well
your job is to fail
if you do things well
the world will hate you
and it will do everything
to destroy you
and if it can't destroy you if you're
too [ __ ] strong
or you're too [ __ ] numb
or you're like me
a little
mixture of like all of the above
not really too strong because i'm not a
badass
i'm a psycho
so i don't feel
most
of the pain
so that
makes you seem
like a badass
and
i felt so much pain
in such a short period of time
that
that
was it called
the soul
i think
left me
broke
died
whatever ran away
and so
when i put my mind to something
i can do it
but that's not what they actually want
they teach you that in school
they teach you that in school
but that's not what they want
they want you to fail they want you to
be a robot they want you to be just
another miserable
pathetic version of them
that's it
if you achieve
anything
other than that without even intending
to achieve it
you'll be cursed
to a life
where most people hate
you where your own family hates you
where
the people that you used to think you
could
go to and
cry on their shoulder
pull back
in disgust
at your presence
let alone
at the possibility of your face touching
their
shoulder
what are you afraid of
what's your
what do you worry about
death
not because i'm scared of dying
because i think it'll hurt i hope it
does
i'm scared of death
because my mother managed to
inflict in me
a belief
that i don't even hold it anymore not
truly but i can't get rid of either
which is
one
there is a hell
and hell
hell is for people like me
demonic creatures
that were never meant for anything other
than
destruction
her words love mine
have you always had this dark
view of the world
before your
two wives
well is five
i got to stay over at my best friend's
house
which was
not the missionary but the pastor's
son
nathan
and uh
we had all these plans
and then come to find out
his parents
were going out of town and his brother
was watching us
so for the next four hours
his older brother
the good
christian boy he was
raped us
his brother
and his brother's best friend
it wasn't fun enough
so he called in his best friend
to join
and make it more enjoyable
when i was nine i was
arrested in
bulgaria
because
my family was accused
of
child pornography
because my parents were missionaries and
because they took pictures
for slides for the christian movies
and
video footages and whatnot
my father had made it out of the country
so i was the man of the family
in that culture
being
nine
you're a full-grown man
i was tortured
for
four and a half days
in ways
i'm not even gonna bother to explain
before
suddenly
my father's friend who was a
uh
american ambassador
some [ __ ] like that
came in
with american military
and
uh
pulled me out
i have always been evil i've always been
dark i've always been in pain
i have never known anything other than
this
reality except for when i died
and that reality was much [ __ ] worse
don't believe the stories of nice floaty
up above the bed
stories and [ __ ] like that no that's not
what happens at least not to people like
me
i hung myself
while i was being put
into
an adult
prison
as a juvenile
in america
because my mother had decided
that she was done with me and my father
so
she lied in a court of law and brought
charges of rape against both
me and him
uh against her
and
my sister
and
all this wonderful stuff
and
the
small town
[Music]
nebraska [ __ ] judge
ate it up
screamed at me for being such a piece of
[ __ ]
they pulled my poetry writing which had
some metallica
poor metallica they always get pulled
into this only
metallica [ __ ] quotes and some
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] like that because
that was the time period
and uh
when bam thinking man i got locked up
so i killed myself
i was dead
according to their charts for an hour
according to my mind
i was dead for two years
i have two years extra memory
try that one out
and nobody will believe you
because this isn't
happy
story tales
of
a five-year-old boy who you know
makes up or
maybe doesn't make up but repeats or
states or whatever the [ __ ] you know his
near-death experience
only to come out later on in life and
say oh it was all a fake but
now because
that's okay
when you
are
we are nothing
just another pathetic demon
ruining
the life of a good christian woman
it doesn't matter if you write a book
nobody's going to read it
i know
i've written a few
victor what's the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
this important lesson
see that split
go down deep inside your soul
and stab yourself
repeatedly until you have no emotions
and do it as soon as possible
and yet at the same time
find someone
that loves you
that you can love
and that's a big deal
that loves you and you can love
and level
killing everything you got
doesn't matter what it is
good bad ugly doesn't matter
just give them everything
and if the world tells you you're evil
for it
who cares
all right victor thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you
sorry about your wife
you